hi I'm Nick Gillespie and I'm with Matt
Welch my co-author of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America today
is ask a libertarian day Marc Hemingway
of The Weekly Standard in hot Air's and
Morrissey asked related question what's
the libertarian position on abortion
Edie specifically asked if libertarian
philosophy puts individual rights
paramount shouldn't libertarians oppose
abortion pretty consistently something
like 30% of self-identified libertarians
are also very strongly pro-life or
anti-abortion I think a lot of people
get to that question in a very similar
way that Ed Morrissey just postulated
it's not a position that I agree with
personally I think abortion should be
legal but it's a position of everything
on the social conservative spectrum that
I have the most respect for
philosophically it is that it's a very
very difficult question a personal
question and I don't think there should
be a litmus test saying you can't be a
libertarian if you don't agree with this
I agree with Matt that there really in
the end there are no litmus test
questions that abortion is not the
deciding question or and your answer to
it is not decisive as to whether or not
you're a libertarian on the thirtieth
anniversary of Roe vs. Wade I wrote a
piece for reason calm talking about how
the kind of social consensus and and to
be blunt the sliding scale of humanity
from fertilization of an egg to the
growth of a fetus to a viable fetus one
that can live outside the outside the
woman outside the mother this is
something that makes intuitive sense to
people it is not a logical answer but
the fact is is that definitions of life
and of death change with time they
change with medical technology and
social understanding what what counted
as a birth in 1900 is not the same as in
2000 or in 1800 I think that we are
getting as we develop more ways of
controlling our sexuality and our
reproduction we are actually seeing the
minimization of abortion as a major
issue in American politics so I respect
the idea of people being against
abortion on demand
I think that they should lobby to change
people's minds but I think that the
legal framework that's in place is
pretty good and that the science
scientific and medical framework that is
in place and is growing will make this
issue less pressing from as the future
unfolds